so you have 12 contestants is it the
right 12 for you
are we sure and then
we kind of changed it we had like one
minute left it's just a lot of emotions
tonight I'm not worried about the people
that went home this evening because
they're all massive stars you know they
have they all have tons of opportunity
and I think a lot of them are gonna make
a real moment of this moment yes I agree
with you there's a whole bunch of talent
speaking of talent I'm going to talk
about this coronation because we are
giddy about it what what is it like for
you
at King Charles so we call them King yet
or do we call them King soon you tell me
his majesty
I met his majesty to to be a few years
ago and he named me as an ambassador to
one of his organizations the British
Asian trust which is a organization that
helps fight to end child trafficking
so I'm also an ambassador for Unicef and
it really aligned with my values and
that's mostly why I'm going to be an
ambassador and to say hey this is me
from the USA but it's so cool hold on
now speaking of the USA do we not we
have an American Idol show are you
hopping on a plane are you going to be
in both places at once how is it going
to work for us I mean you'll just have
to tune in and wait and see
I love it we will wait and see
um
do we what about the Met Gala next week
I know we have idle shows in the Met
Gala do we lose you at the Met gal do we
have you at the mech Allen we have you
here where are you I'm sending Zoe
deschanela in my place
okay
Zoe I love you
[Music]
okay